autrefois métier d'homme à pied ou à
cheval aujourd'hui entièrement
accessible à la femme
le métier de facteur s'exerce aussi
désormais à vélo à moto ou en voiture
véronique un genre que fait partie de
cette nouvelle génération qui défriche
une parité encore à l'état embryonnaire
à la réunion cette préposée à la
distribution qui sillonnent le centre
ville de saint-benoît tous les jours
vous une incontestable passion pour son
métier elle nous emmène pour ne tourner
au pas de charge
juste après avoir résolu ce petit
problème d'identité
comment vous préférez quand vous appelle
proposé à très somalie capteurs ben
souvent les gens disent factrice donc je
trouve ça joli c'est pas encore dans le
dictionnaire mais je pense que ça
viendra
ce métier est ce que c'était un jour oui
ça a été un choix j'ai passé mon
concours en métropole et j'ai été reçu
là bas j'ai commencé à travailler enfin
paris d'une bonne dizaine d'années et je
suis revenu à la réunion en 92 comment
ça s'est passé pour
nationaliste et je n'avais pas été muté
en mieux à chaque vin d'os et de en
plein gré je suis revenu
petit peu marre de rester là bas on
applique la cave venu comme ça est
arrivé ici j'ai attendu mon mari
travaille à nan parce que c'est le
simplet ça se passe comme ça à la poste
un homme fiche de paye et puis on serait
inscrit sur un tableau à la réunion donc
j'ai fait ça et après j'ai été appelé à
la poste a travaillé 1,95 en tant que
contractuels ai-je été réintégrés sur
saint benoît 1998 - et organisez votre
survie de travail matin on commence à 7h
sur le bureau de symbole mais je sais
pas le cas de tous les deux ils ont
commandé un bureau éloigné de saint
denis
lentement ça c'était parce que comme le
camion il est arrivé un peu plus tard
donc ça sert à rien
d'arrivée avant est donné par notre
courrier pour cette heure c'est un
travail collectif jusqu'à 7h30
c'est à dire que tous les préposés sont
la literie il sépare le courrier de
chaque facteur donc à 7h30 un long jeu
laisse toutes nos bases c'est-à-dire moi
par exemple facteur 3 je relate toutes
les cases 3 j'emmène stationnement
position et là je commence mon découpage
le découpage c'est les rues déjà fait un
peu en euros et comme on l'a fini ça on
pique le courrier c'est à dire quoi en
classe dans l'ordre de la tournée lors
des numéros tôt et puis voilà
et apprendre comment des mandats s'il ya
on se prépare à partir en suisse elle
tout ça si on a trop de courrier on met
ça dans un sac en fait un petit dépôt si
on peut pas tout prendre
et puis
fait la tournée on récupère le sac en
chemin qu'on a déposé chez une personne
bien précise que la peau c'est au
courant donc voilà et puis bien 20 ans
ou avant de partir on fait nos ordres de
faire suivre cédé que les gens qui sont
partisans quitter leur domicile soit
définitivement soit parti en vacances
donc on fait suivre le courrier il ya
des gens qui n'habitent plus là donc il
faut aussi de voir un petit peu tout ça
de retourner à l'expéditeur le disant
que sa personne n'habite plus la halle
puis voilà on nettoie tôt et c'est fini
on chez nous quand on a fini
quelle que soit l'heure en général vers
13h30 14h ça fonctionne jour où il
travaille
oui oui en fonction du travail on peut
finir un peu plus tard un peu plus tôt
aussi à mon courrier
mais sinon ça dépend aussi un petit peu
de la personne de sa rapidité ou de sa
lenteur mes collègues rigole souvent
mais parce que moi comme ils triment
danse en même temps alors
on m'a charrie souvent là dessus mais
disons que moi ça me donne mon rythme
que celle que vous soyez une femme mais
ce qu'il voulait vous êtes une façon
particulière et ce cas une solidarité
qui existe à la poste et en particulier
celle de distribution oui oui il faut le
dire parce que bon en tant que femme des
fois si on a un petit problème avec la
moto on va savoir mettre l'huile au
l'essence ou des trucs comme ça mais
disons que des fois il nous arrive
d'avoir un petit problème que pas très
compliqué puis bon ils sont là au niveau
du travail c'est pareil dans le que non
je crois que c'est un plus d'être une
femme dans ce travail là ils sont quand
même assez solidaire même si le temps en
temps vous serez chargé un petit peu
gentiment mais bon ça ça crée l'ambiance
parce qu'on peut dire que le préposé et
l'image de la poste
oui bien sûr oui oui énormément
énormément parce que les
la rue y pense qu'on en sait tous le
pratiquement de tout savoir donc on
essaye de se mettre un petit peu
diapason mais malheureusement il des
fois y'a tellement de produits qui
arrivent on ne sait pas tout la tenue à
thème une grande importance pour le
personnel de discrétion moi je pense que
oui c'est ça nous plaît ça permet de
distinguer le facteur
autre par rapport puisque comme on est
en contact souvent avec les gens que
quand même que les gens puissent
reconnaître au moins le facteur qui
arrive on peut arriver à pied donc c'est
pas censé de savants dont moi je trouve
que c'est très important parce qu'elle
fait à cette distinction
et puis je sais c'est pour la maison
aussi donc la poste on y fait partie
donc moi je sais que c'est très
important
est ce qu'elle est tenue spéciale pour
les femmes on a un certain montant qu'il
nous est attribué et donc après par
rapport à ça tu te veux tu fais un choix
tu peux choisir des jupes ou pantalons
shorts et bermudas plutôt un t-shirt
chemise casquette ceinture cravate
l'ensemble bien mais à bhl la vaysse de
pluie tous les gants pour les gens qui
font de la moto
les chaussures les bottines ya tout et
pour tout ça était quoi le pantalon
c'est ce qu'il ya de plus pratique le
jean
les bons les chaussures chaussures ou
bottines en hiver j'aime bien les
victimes mais quand il pleut si bien
huilée tee shirt qui sont quand même
assez coloré dollar
j'en ai je fait que ces choses et la
casquette est ce qu'elle est obligatoire
les peaux obligatoire mais disons que
quand le soleil tape très dur ça rend
service et puis je cours c'est joli
bonjour bonjour les hirondelles via
della sera posée et il est essentiel est
que le bureau de la poster au oui oui il
rassure c'est à dire que le client nous
considèrent comme le lien qui va aller
ils vont ils ont besoin des
renseignements des fois ils ont pas
envie d'aller à la porte juste pour
renseignements et des fois nous on peut
leur donner ou si on ne peut pas le
faire on peut les diriger vers les
personnes aptes pour pour la question
auquel elle voudrait une réponse
émotionnelle en général ça s'arrange
très bien quand même sur lequel on de
céline l'école en bout de moi j'essaye
de rendre le plus possible c'est à dire
bon des personnes qui ne peuvent parler
la poste vont chercher leur pain je les
emmène des enveloppes timbrées
mais man surtout sur cinq moines j'ai un
gros secteur c'est le centre-ville
énormément de commerçants de personnes
âgées donc je fais le maximum et ça se
passe très bien
donc je m'appelle le matin gaza pas le
gros et moi je les emmène sa dans la
matinée demont est content quels sont
les principaux risques de ses métiers a
le plus gros risque c'est le chien fait
chier les chiens particulier des fois on
se méfie pas passé montre que le chien
là l'air comme ça là elle bouge pas un
jour une semaine deux semaines et puis
un jour je ne sais pas ce qui lui passe
par la tête qui vous sautent dessus au
moment où on s'y attend le moins en
général donc face à ça on n'a pas
tellement beaucoup de parade c'est à
dire il faut demander aux gens de bien
enfermer leurs chiens donc des fois sans
faire exprès c'est le portail qui
étaient ouverts ou des trucs comme ça
donc
puis ben on peut commander en moto ou en
voiture on peut tomber il ya ce
risque-là aussi surtout quand il pleut
il faut faire très attention gravillons
et tout ça mais bon est-ce que vous vous
avez déjà été mordu par ma chère nous
déchire oh oui plusieurs fois plusieurs
fois donc c'est souvent jambes là
nous attaquent le plus rapidement
possible oui et puis bon une fois j'ai
été sérieusement mordu en métropole mais
là heureusement c'était l'hiver j'avais
mon groupe une cadence du tout je me
suis envolée j'ai créé le temps que le
gars il arrive donc quand même le chien
avec un homme bien mordu et puis ils ont
fait piquer le chien parce que bon il
n'y avait pas d'autre solution dans la
vie puis dans ces cas là la poste porte
plainte quoi d'accord et c'est dommage
je vais non ça arrive
c'est un travail qui me laisse beaucoup
de temps libre oui oui ce j'ai
pratiquement mais après midi puisque bon
en terminant à 1h30 2h 2h 2h30 je suis
chez moi au maximum donc ça vous permet
quand même d'aller chercher ma fille à
l'école germaine jamais à l'école mais
je vais la chercher
j'aime bien lire énormément même je lis
beaucoup donc je lis beaucoup jamais
permis phase et deux heures d'ailleurs
on a un peu partout faux et donc bien ça
m'a permis d'avoir des passe temps comme
ça quoi
d'accord et comme moi j'ai choisi
l'europe haut de cycle c'est à dire je
travaille cinq semaines et une semaine
je ne travaille pas ça me permet aussi
d'avoir une semaine aux parties vont
avec mes enfants
pendant les vacances scolaires non c'est
bien si c'est pas les vacances scolaires
je les emmène à l'école donc ils sont
contents ça me permet de faire mon
travail tranquillement le matin d'avoir
mis un après midi tranquille
vous commencez tout commence tôt le
matin c'est ma grosse galère parce que
je suis plus tard et les stars donc le
matin s'ils appellent mari quand même le
café ou les filles c'est dur dur le
facteur était un métier serait à des
hommes à l'eau cette année banque
nationale des cinq qui font si lippi
sait maintenant il y en a elle a pas mal
y en a énormément métropole un peu moins
la réunion il y en a pas mal dans l'est
je pense que n'importe quelle femme est
capable de le faire si elles le veulent
c est un beau métier c'est un métier
plaisant on a énormément de contacts
avec les gens il faut aimer donc moi je
pense que c est la portée de toutes les
femmes